yeah we were talking about the whole
loser women think because there was that
post
um or there was something dropped in the
chat about it earlier in the week um did
you want to touch on that moth
uh I'm not remembering exactly what the
loser women chat is but I mean I know
that you know it's it's this idea that
uh just like there are men that are set
their own way there are women that are
sent their own way the only problem is
that but are there liquor
what's that but I mean like are there
really women like like femcells because
I don't think there are I mean there's
there's a very very huge value that's
the thing it's it's because neither each
side is valuing something differently
like you can tell a woman is a loser if
she is past a certain age and she
doesn't have you know a loving family or
a relationship or a man that she values
yeah but like a 42 year old chick that's
that's like past her smv Peak she's not
gonna be fertile or she's at the end of
her fertility Windows Society still
tells her that she's beautiful I mean in
fact Society will tell her that she's
beautiful at any size
yeah she's miserable society's wrong
yeah I mean it's that's what it boils
down to I mean yeah she can have her her
uh mainstream media and she can have her
Facebook comments or whatever that is
but she at the end of the day she has to
be alone with herself and she has to
look herself in the mirror and I think I
I do think deep down like women as much
as they want to believe it they really
don't
I'm I'm convinced that all females want
to be mothers
so you you
you want to do you don't want to do the
one thing that we're literally hardwired
in our brains to do and that millions
and millions and literally billions of
people have wanted to do for myself
I don't know I'd be very interested in
figuring out I'm guessing it's they've
been told to chase a career and that a
degree frame to Mahogany with little
letters after name is important but I
know women that don't want kids I know
women that are like you know that that
are mates or that are you know they
they're nannies they're like oh my dog
is my kid or like my nanny kids right so
yeah they raise other kids a lot of
school a lot of school teachers like
you're doing it in some capacity
um do you think it's do you think it's
because these because these women like
get to the point where it's like the
chances of me achieving that and then
all of this like Vortex of [ __ ] that
they keep hearing their entire lives
about you know
Chase your career get a degree make
money pay taxes all that kind of sort of
stuff
and that they
are so strong and independent today and
that they don't need no man and a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
sort of thing like I think there's a lot
of things colluding against society and
the betterment of society you know to
the degree where
this is where we're at today like that's
literally what my Twitter timeline is
it's like hey guys this is where we're
at today like look at this new [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like hey there's something new here
well there are far more Sinister and
means that play and there's there
there's far more incentive from the
mainstream media to keep women plugged
in than there is met and right there's
far more in it for the people behind
behind closed doors that want to keep
women buying their feminism lies and
that sort of thing because women can be
plugged in just like men but it's uh
there's there's far more incentive to
keep women you know their heads buried
in the sand to what uh actually is going
to make them happy that's a perfect
Point moth I think it is on politicians
and marketing and everything they use it
they plug women in Far easier and as a
lot of you know I was back in Ireland
um in August and I said some things
around family members and it was
completely red pill and it did not go
down well and a family member went to
college about 10 years ago she was only
interested English literature and
writing Stephen King stuff and you know
a couple of years into college she
started to have opinions on Israel the
pro-life movement capitalism I could see
her getting plugged in and buying
everything and when I was home this time
she had she's 28 now and she had a
little yappy dog
and they were all like oh did you see
her dog I said yeah I said and the
reason she got that dog is because her
motherhood jeans have kicked in and she
needs to mother on something and
considering she's been plugged in and
become anti-man and the patriarchy she
needed something to mod around so she
went out and bought that yappy dog there
was just Jaws dropping everywhere
because everyone else was like oh your
dog is so cute and I was like well she
got the dog to replace the baby that she
wanted to have and and that's that's it
if we if we you know if she respond to
that by the way she called me an [ __ ]
I think and I can't believe
and as you know when I get called an
[ __ ] it's like a compliment it's the
biggest compliment in the world to me
but um and you could see people realized
what what it was she was pushing into
her mid to late 20s and she wanted a
mother something she bought a yappy dog
and she still hangs out with all her
walk college buddies and they just they
you know you go girl you got a dog I
mean that that's you know obviously her
DNA was telling her something and now
she's picking up poop and pee and can't
train the dog properly and but yeah you
go you know I'll tell you what it is
guys I I think it's because men and
fathers are no longer respected and
valued you know like even even fathers
today have a difficult time leading the
family leading their kids leading their
uh partner wife spouse whatever you want
to call them
um they're they're constantly [ __ ]
testers they're constantly challenged
and the vast majority of them fail it
and even if you pass it like even if you
put your foot down and you may tan a
strong masculine frame you've still got
the entire world society culture you
know the entire plugged in Matrix you
know if you will trying to convince and
brainwash
you know these these these kids of yours
these women in your life that
um you're wrong you're the bad guy uh
you know somebody hurt you you've got a
small PP you know whatever the you know
lyrics happen to be at that time but
that's just the way that it is right
it's like you know it's gonna be it's
always going to be an uphill battle for
guys like
you know I've had a few guys
um ask me a few times over the last
couple months on the unplugged Alpha
podcast
um
kids I want to have kids blah blah and
it's like look even if you're gonna
homeschool them do it on a ranch in the
middle of nowhere and you've got a good
you know wife good mother sock you know
that's totally aligned with your values
that's great but wait until you put a
screen in their hand
and they download apps like Tick Tock
and the other crap and they start
hanging out with kids that are all
plugged into blue pill lies sort of
thing and I mean like when we were kids
like even 50 will Echo this and I'm sure
you guys will remember because you know
you're a little bit younger but you're
kind of on the precipice of when like
handheld phones sort of became very very
popular but like even when I was a
teenager I thought my parents were
idiots right and my my source of
influence came from magazines like
Thrasher or muscle media you know 2000
magazine or my schoolmates or music you
know that was the extent of it but now
you've got that and then you've got
everything else on a handheld device
telling and and it's and it's even worse
than what it was when I was a kid like
at least when I was a kid they would say
you know get a skateboard and go flying
off a jump ramp and who cares if you
crack your skull it doesn't matter
you'll be fine you know your bones of
men sort of thing now it's like they're
telling kids to cook chicken with uh was
it Quaaludes or something I don't know
nyquilades are back yeah I've heard some
lewd references later
yeah it's just like some of the
stupidest [ __ ] and it's like and these
kids take it like Hook Line and Sinker
dude rich on the flip side I told you my
son and all his Bros he's 14 or watching
Andrew Tate videos on the bus and like
he's 14 and him and his crew are going
to the gym and you know that you know he
asks me more and more about Andrew Tate
and I start I I you know I told him I
said I want you watching this content I
sent him the five hour video with with
the Ted interview and I started
explaining a couple of things he said to
me um there's this girl that sits behind
me in school and she's really cute and I
said ignore her I said 10 she doesn't
exist bro and get on with your you know
and that is one of the positives and
again why did they ban Ted because they
didn't want young influential and you
know young up and coming men getting
influenced by this stuff what does your
daughter's second tape by the way
um I I don't think she has any any
opinion and that's why I'm starting to
pay more of attention to you know the
girly stuff her and her friends are
doing with Tick Tock and all that but
she's still into
um you know I want to expose her to take
it as well because I wanted I wanted you
look like I find the vast majority of
women are opposed to the narratives that
he talks about there's there's like the
women that are pro masculine messages
like the stuff that Tate really goes
hardcore on there are very few and far
between right
um the boys seem to I think that his
audience is a lot a lot younger than
mine like I would say most of his
followers are probably in their teens
and maybe early 20s whereas my guys are
definitely mostly over 25 like they're
not as kiddish
um even though we're basically saying
very similar things but I always find it
interesting when I hear about the
feedback from kids I was on a um I was
on a zoom a couple of days ago so I had
my uh
um Forum meeting you know the guys that
are in the business uh tier and one of
the guys was saying like yeah my kids
absolutely love your [ __ ] rich like you
know my 12 year old my 14 year old like
they're like it's so cool that you're in
this group sort of thing it's like
it'd be awesome if my own kid thought
the same thing right now because I mean
she's very happy with the money that I
make but she doesn't like the way that I
make it it's weird rich I think one
thing to note too like you have to
remember when we were all teenagers like
it was cool to be anti-establishment to
like be a rebel to go against what your
parents and teachers or whatever
told you to do and when I was coming up
like 90s time frame like the US is the
US culture it was more it's kind of like
shifting more liberal but like there
still were a lot of conservative values
so it was cool to like go against like
the man and now
um a couple years ago I had a beach
house in California and I rented a room
to a young kid he was like 19 going on
20. and when his friends would come in I
noticed like wow his friends were
actually all really cool kids like
they're well adjusted they're they don't
have the blue pill type mindset and I
asked him I was like dude I thought
these California kids were woke as hell
and he this kid told me he's like yeah
all the losers are he's like all the
cool kids are going the other way
because
because of the reason I just told you
that it's it's cool to go against like
the mainstream narrative or the so I
think the pendulum's gonna swing back in
the other direction I had a couple quick
comments too on previous topics um
I know yeah I'll try to make them
questions the answer to uh why women
don't want to have kids I've actually
had Girls Tell me like some of the more
attractive ones that uh it destroys
their bodies and that's just a no-go for
them so like kind of the more it's a
little selfish but that's a big reason
it destroys our bodies and then uh we've
talked about this a lot girls with dogs
I have a hard rule that no girls but
dogs are allowed in my place I had a
girl yesterday she's like oh I can't
bring my dog I can't bring my dog I'm
like absolutely not because usually
we've talked about their finances being
screwed up their dogs are misbehaved too
I've never had a girlfriend in My Places
and not piss all over it chew my [ __ ]
speaker cable claw my furniture so hard
roll no no dogs allowed in my place now
if it's my dogs my brother's a dog
trainer yeah they can bring him but uh
yeah hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out